ja this is first before the
velvet revolution can be counted among the
founding moments of the
contemporary european union as
we know it today it
opened the see the
political reunification of the  europe reunification
based on the values of common inspiration after
the fall of the berlin wall the v
lvet revolution was the turni
g point of the year 1940 80.9 as a you
g journalist i participated in these
historic moments with great
from enthusiastic I am proud to chair
today a parliament which brings together the
European countries of the west and the west
of the south and the north
the error was built by overcoming the
traumatisms produced by nazism
and communism
the  work of memory that we must
do everything is rarer and more important
than ever I congratulate you for this
great initiative
the values that have made it possible to ma
e the union stronger we need
stronger union that it  is
the  motivates the motivations and its beautiful
initiatives a for all the
european parliament thank you thank you
[Applause]
by staff of the binomials oft innovation
entitled in free society i want it to
rizhao partners in europe prosperous in
europe we continue local
channel factors plus an example
[Applause  ]